with evie because i had her
in london and i had to go back to work
on a episodic tv show which is the event
which was in vancouver
and so i had to travel with her
and at the time chan wasn't available to
be
with us for most of the parts so it was
me my doula
and evie all by ourselves traveling at
six weeks
that's jenna dewan talking about the
challenges she faced after welcoming
daughter everly in 2013. the candid
convo happened on the deer gabby podcast
the 40 year old actress says her
ex-husband channing tatum
wasn't around shortly after everly's
birth due to hectic and conflicting work
schedules
because i thought okay i think i can do
that you know it'll be like two months
after and i'll be able to have her on
set
that was really hard because that was
long hours
i did have her on set with me constantly
it was just really difficult
jenna says she felt a lot of postpartum
anxiety during that time but clarified
on instagram that she was not
slamming channing just speaking on the
experience of being a working parent
i just never stopped you know it was
like you're you're up a couple times in
the night then you're working all day
you're i was breastfeeding i was pumping
i was
without a partner i mean it was just
craziness right
jenna and janine eventually split in
2018 and everly
is now 8 years old jenna is now engaged
to actor steve kazee
they welcomed their son callum last year
do you want to talk about new love
i mean are you happy because we love you
so we want you to be happy yes i'm very
happy thank you for asking
jenna says she's grateful steve was
around so much after welcoming their son
this time around i was so grounded
even though the world was crazy i was
home and in this love nest and it was
great it was like me and steve callum
and evie just cuddling and
it was so lovely after jenna and
channing split a source told et the pair
was focused on maintaining a good
co-parenting relationship for everly's
sake
and in 2017 jenna praised her ex for
being the kind of dad
who really goes the extra mile we were
watching ellen
together and he came on again singing
let it go as a princess and she was like
oh like it was like nothing
[Music]
[Applause]
officially our child thinks this is
normal that her
father dresses up like elsa and sings
let it go it was quite funny actually
[Music]
you